hélas non
[Musique]
chaque halte ainsi qu'aux lignes et que
je suis né
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir qui est inscrite olivier
c'est patrick ollivier olivier d'accord
alors il dit vous êtes le pilote de
ligne oui et ils n'ont pas peur les
passagers quand vous dites le
commandement de funès est heureux de
vous accueillir aborde maintenant non
général j'ai un accueil assez
sympathique
une fois il ya quand même une dame qui a
demandé si j'avais mon permis de
conduire
ah ouais quand même oui alors je lui ai
fait savoir qu'il me restait deux points
pour le vol et donc vous vous êtes
radiologue
oui vous êtes de rendre les les fils
évidemment de louis de funès et vous
publiez louis de funès ne parlait pas
trop de moi les enfants au cherche midi
voilà alors louis de funès est né en
donc c'est à dire qu'il aurait eu 90 ans
aujourd'hui 1 il est à courbevoie son
père était avocat et son père donc votre
grand-père avait fui l'espagne parce
qu'il voulait épouser une fille quoi et
les parents de la fille voulait pas
d'entité partie carrément de il l'a fait
dans l'oeil
ouais il l'a carrément enlevé mais il
paraissait assez court en espagne 1
une nuit elle était très bourgeoise un
très bon milieu et parents voulaient pas
en entendre parler et ils ont passé la
frontière c'est comme ça qu'ils se
retrouvaient en france alors le père de
louis de funès votre grand-père donc
semer en arrivant en francité avocat et
donc il était avocat quand ils arrivent
en france il se met dans les émeraudes
synthétique ça marche pas du tout parce
qu'ils étaient daltonien oui c'est un
gars qui distinguait pas le faire du
bruit
après il part au venezuela enfin c'est
quelqu'un qui était pas très sérieux en
fait votre grand père je crois que du
titre très méditerranéen il passait donc
c'était un rêveur bon puis après il est
allé toujours pour les pierres au
venezuela parce que je crois qu'il ya
des mines d'émeraudes
ouais bon bein il n'en est certes pas
très bien passée mais il est parvenu y
est ma grand-mère est allé le rechercher
par la peau des fesses au bout de vingt
quatre cinq ans parle à la ramener mais
très malin il a terminé à malaga très
très très mal un tuberculeux alors ce
qui est très drôle c'est que louis de
funès a rencontré votre votre mère donc
pendant l'occupation il était pianiste
de jazz et un jury dans une boîte de
jazz et il ya un officier allemand qui
drague celle qui est devenue votre mère
par la suite et lui pour la protéger il
a dit non
suit son fiancé c'est extraordinaire
alors là il a bénéficié d'un passe droit
c'est qu'il était pianiste et les
allemands c'est très curieux vénérait
les musiciens où il a dit tiens c'est
votre fiancée il abandonne tout de suite
il a passé beaucoup de barrages ces
normes suivant une scène de film quoi
c'était à t'imaginer louis de funès qui
sont il a fait l'un bliss voilà il m'est
chère à hergé pas cours il rentre
brouille avant l'heure on retrouve
exactement la niche est devenu vrai donc
il est devenu vraiment le fiancé de huy
après sur le quai de métro voilà c'est
extraordinaire cette histoire très belle
histoire oui sont connus d'une façon
assez romanesque mais profonds comme pas
mal d'autres parisiens qui attrapait les
métros investir piqué fusillé l'un meurt
et alors il est déjà marié
en fait louis de funès le guide a nommé
herman cain était marine avons oublié
art et tendre et sensuel mais pas à sky
il s'était marié 6,7 en avant puis ce
tueur et est depuis toujours pareil on a
du mal à le croire mais c'est la guerre
et il dit à ma mère j'ai les briques
tout d'un coup il a réalisé que je
devais déjà marié alors ils se sont
rencontrés tous germaine a trouvé ma
mère très joli
ma mère a trouvé le futur mari de
germaine comme quoi les femmes ont
souvent les mêmes goûts fois son goût
aussi
et du coup ils sont très amies toutes là
leur vie ouais mais ils sont restés amis
dont toujours alors ce qui est très bien
aussi c'est très film c'est que il n'y
avait pas de boulot louis de funès au
départ donc anti chercher du travail
comme ça ils et elles se baladent et
l'après midi devant le fouquet's où à
l'époque avaient tous les gens du cinéma
qui étaient là évidemment c'était le
quartier général du cinéma français dont
il passait comme ça suivra dessous mais
alors ils ont marché peut-il arriver en
bas il remontait sa durée 4h 5h en
espérant rencontrer quelqu'un est
quelquefois il y avait un type qui
sortent un metteur en scène à bompas et
par hasard tient et c'est comme ça que
dégoter des petits rôles dur bhatia fait
une journée de marche
journée il a ramé parce que c'est
l'époque où enfin beaucoup de beaucoup
de comédiens ont fait ça mais c'est
l'époque où il jouait au théâtre tous
ces gens là ensuite il avait deux
cabarets dans la nuit deux cabarets
jusqu'à 3 heures du matin très tôt le
matin ils retournaient tournée il a
toujours eu peur que ça atteint votre
père je crois que c'est un peu comme
tous les gens qui ont eu des débuts très
difficiles
bon il était très conscient que c'était
un métier enfin harris qui disait si
j'me casse une jambe c'est cuit ce qui
est très drôle c'est qu'au départ donc
les réalisateurs les metteurs en scène
mettez louis de funès avec des grosses
bonnes femmes pour faire un effet un peu
du bout quoi pour faire quelque chose de
comique et votre mère ne lui plaisait
pas du tout et c'est votre mère qui a
choisi claude gensac pour eux le comique
c'est un croupier on a mené une grosse
vingtaine a rigolé et est la presse est
au théâtre et pour les gendarmes qu'elle
a choisi claude gensac mais avons quand
même quand il nya qu il a joué en
tournée en ce cas il n'a eu et maria
pacôme way et c'était formidable
alors en fait votre père quand il a
connu votre mère elle avait un peu plus
d'argent elle a été levée dans un
château etc
donc quand il a eu de l'argent lui lui a
acheté un appartement au parc monceau
pour lui il a voulu lui recréer le cadre
de vie de ces enfants avaient vécu dans
un hôtel particulier du parc monceau il
a acheté un appartement dans le parc on
sera là pour qu elle l a même vu carey
il était quand ils ont eu ces périodes
très difficiles elle a quand même tout
abandonner pour lui alors il lui avait
dit je te recréerait tout ce que tu as
perdu gris la presse est un destin
extraordinaire privé bien sûr alors que
les chauriens c'est qu'à un moment elle
elle hérite du château donc lui aussi
et alors là comme tous les anciens
pauvres c'est à dire qu'il a peur des
cambriolages dans ce château
il passe son temps à se balader avec un
trousseau 30 clé parce qu'ils voient là
une fille complètement en quoi comme les
gens qui ont pas été habitués étant
jeune sans doute à y faire mais c'est
tout ses portes les secrétaires clé de
caves
le prix de la porte de la chapelle tous
a été fermée tous les jours à la même
heure ça prenait une heure et demie pour
fermer toutes les portes et on
l'attendait nous à table on attendait
qui viennent pour dîner april asnières
vérifier ça reprenait un quart d'heure
et en guérit pire est derrière car ce
qui est incroyable c'est que ''c'était
fanatiques des clés des serrures des
cadenas et des alarmes le jour de ses
obsèques
l'alarmé s'est déclenchée
le convoi quittait on entendu des
alarmes hurler je ne sais pas assez mari
sans bruit avec un coup heureux que tu
aies un peu bourré étaient les faire
fermer près du truc d'alcool ouais alors
avec les autres acteurs c'est très
intéressant ce que vous racontez il est
peu d'atomes crochus avec gaba parce
qu'en fait un jour il avait demandé à
gabin si vous avez vu ces films et
l'autre avaient dit non j'en ai vu au
cas j'avais beaucoup vexé en fait
c'était pas très bien élevés c'est une
danse étaient sur le même plateau le
journaliste qui peuvent nous avait vus
ils passent d'abord voir mon père vous
aimez les films de gabin pas forcément
je les aime tous il était un fan aussi
d'ailleurs et il passe la loge d'après
en longe ont eu aucun train n'est pas
très fin ouais alors était pote avec
bourvil
ah oui oui très et ennemi de jean marais
il disait janot tu donnes glynn haïti en
fait il avait une réputation de
l'emmerdeur parce qu'il vise est très
créatif et sur les tournages je voulais
absolument participer à la réalisation
un 7 avril vérifier tout dans le cinéma
français c'était quand même assez
catastrophique je crois est évidemment
les gens qui travaillent mal disent que
vous êtes un emmerdeur
ouais ouais et les gens qui travaillent
bien disent que vous êtes parfait
toujours la même histoire partout alors
il avait du mal à sortir parce que
évidemment tout le monde lui disait
allez faites moi ça fait moins ça alors
il faisait une petite grimace
on va quand même c'est normal c'est au
bout d'un moment ce seul fatigué donc
quand il sortit il avait un passe
montagne et lunettes noires est
extraordinaire à voir non ils se
mettaient un passe montagne pour pas
être connues on reconnaissait encore
plus sec et d'un terrible il y avait des
gens quand même qui est qui était
inquiète et qui avait un toupet monstre
je me souviens dans un avion il ya un
monsieur qui s'est installé à côté de
lui il allait 90 à paris et qui
permettent à côté de vous comme ça vous
allez me faire des grimaces pendant le
vol ça va faire passer le voyage est
alors il était tellement renfermé chez
lui qu'il sortait plus dans l'est dans
les magasins et un jour il voit la télé
y voit des caddies à la télé edit c'est
quoi ce truc leur laisser les petits
chariots qu'on a dans un supermarché
maintenant il sait même pas que ça
existait et c'est là où ma mère s'est
dit il ya quand même quelque chose qui
va pas qu'il va plus là il est trop
mince culte alors ce qu'on apprend dans
votre bouquin à quoi il avait un projet
que polanski oui oui là il rencontrait
polanski l'admiré beaucoup
il avait beaucoup aimé le bal des
vampires ray juillet et polansky là mais
aussi se rencontrer ils ont déjeuné
ensemble dans un restaurant parisien
et il avait un projet puis les affaires
ont éloigné polanski de france et du
cinéma ça s'est jamais fait c'est
dommage il reste qu'avec ça aurait été
drôle
alors aujourd'hui qui sont les
successeurs de votre père pour vous
christian clavier
la contrefaçon anneaux faut l'arrêter en
douane suis là c'est pas normal qu'on
saisit des sacs vuitton c'est une
contrefaçon
alors la pure empochera les douaniers
jeu il passerait plus à vous trouvez que
c'est la contrefaçon de la contrefaçon
ne sait même pas de limitation c'est de
la contrefaçon et de la récupération
alors là je suis très m bon il ya des
gens qui sont expirés il ya d'autres
gens mais là nos à je suis très remonté
ah ouais mais depuis quand depuis
toujours ou à nord depuis qu'il s'est
mis à limiter avance est un excellent
acteur ma chérie dans le père noël est
une ordure c'est après comme j'ai
commencé avant le plagiat des limites
michaël youn je trouvais que il a
quelque chose de ces derniers jeux je
pense que si mon père voyait tous les
acteurs il leur père ait énormément il
dirait surtout qu'ils ont un très bon
tempérament et mais qui sont pas du tout
ce sont pas des joues pas dans le même
genre je dire mais de son style à lui je
pense qu'il n'y en a pas et puis y'a pas
de raison qu'il y en ait l'armée a
ajouté garcia qui est formidable et
garcia et elie semoun qui est
sensationnel à peu près la même vue
d'ailleurs dès demain un métier que lui
comme si quand il dit que quand il dit
qu'il joue des personnages qui n'émet
qui n'aimerait pas être c'est tout à
fait ce que pensent et mon père aussi
grandin muriaux la wii il aura dit quel
tempérament elle extraordinairement il a
gardé un film c'est sûr il avait adoubé
coluche il avait accepté et savaient pas
les rapports de rivalité très bien
entendu rien entendu en plus chez
coluche on mangeait bien c'était tout
pour plaire à mon père il allait manger
chez lui tout le monde les amis
faisaient la cuisine ils étaient ils
étaient ravis
[Musique]
deux mois les gens tendent
c'est lui
j'vous dis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors quand il a fait rabbi jacob vote
clair il a dit ce film m'a lavé l'esprit
ça veut dire quoi ça oui tout le monde a
au moins ils étaient ils étaient francs
parce qu'au fond peut-être que dans
rabbi jacob il a découvert un monde qui
ne connaissait à 102 voix là il parlait
souvent seul avez l'âme parce qu'ils
considéraient qu'ils avaient tous les
défauts du monde tous les défauts de la
terre et qu'il fallait faire absolument
une introspection pour 0 la l'info faut
vider tout ça il était toujours très
inquiets mais j'ai toujours un peu de
jalousie des choses comme ça il a bien
des défauts quand même ce louis de funès
ben oui ils étaient casse-pieds d'abord
c'est gaspiller